على الرغم من المحادثات الجاريه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم الساريه في جده
والبدن المتتاليه المعلنه لم تتوقف
الاشتباكات في الخرطوم فطرفان وفق الخبراء
لم يسبق لهما خوض حرب شوارع في عاصمه ولا
يستطيع احد منهما حسمها سريعا وبالتالي
يسود قلق من ان تطول الحرب فوجود قدرات
متساويه بين طرفي الصراع الى جانب الاجلاء
العديد من الاجانب واستعداد اخرين لمبادره
السودان يحتمل ان يكون الطرفان يتحضران
لصراعا طويل الامد من اجل السيطره على
البلاد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات